يوجد في هذا الصياد المصري في وسط مياه
نهر النيل في مستهل رحله لم تعد فيها
الاسماك صيدا ثمينا فحسب فكل ما يلتقط من
النهر باب رزق جديدا حتى ولو كانت بعض
القوارير البلاستيكيه التي تطوف على السطح
كهداء مبادره ليست جديده حيث اطلقت عام
واستمرت حتى يومنا هذا تفتح باب رزقا اخر
للصيادين وتسهم في الحفاظ على المظهر
الحضري للنهر عبر تنظيف مجراه من المخلفات
البلاستيكيه وتوعيه الناس بخطوره هذه
المخلفات
وبرده السمك في النيل احنا صيادين والسمك
في النيل جل جل جل من القزاز اللي كان
بيبقى مرمي في النيل يمين وشمال وعلى
الجناب فبرده السمك جل وبرده مفيد ان احنا
بننظف النيل هو مجموعه من الناس اما يعني
احنا الصيادين بالسيدات كلنا على بعض ممكن
نوصل لغايه 100 لكن احنا متخدم او بنحافظ
على النيل 100 مليون وعايزين ننشر الوعي
عشان كل المصريين يكونوا معنا فيري نايل
بس اينما كانوا في المحافظات يكونوا جزء
من باري نايل حتى بروحهم واستهلاكهم اليوم
يقل ويلموا زباله من النيل لو شافوها
وهكذا يسلم والصيادونا كل هذه المخلفات
البلاستيكيه الى مركز متخصصا لاعاده
تدويرها ويقوم باعطائهم مبلغا معينه من
المال مقابل كل كيلو جرام واحد من
المخلفات التي تسمم النهر وكائناته الحيه
وتتراوح المخلفات بين 10 اطنان
اشاره في الشهر الواحد في الصيف مقارنه مع
نحو سبعه اطنان في كل شهر من اشهر الشتاء
للصيادين السمك تقريبا
عددهم 65 صياد سمك دلوقتي اا
بيجمعوا المخلفات وبيستفيدوا ماديا
واقتصاديا من سعر البلاستيك اللي احنا
بنذيذ عادات هذه القوارب بحصاد اليوم من
البلاستيك الضار في محاوله لان تبقى صوره
النيل لبراقه كما تبدو بعدسات الكاميرات
من بعيد